no
[Música]
pues hoy vamos a platicar sobre la
ironía de la historia de méxico todas
las historias de todos los países tienen
villanos tienen héroes tienen relatos
fantásticos tienen batallas épicas por
ejemplo en méxico tenemos este bandolero
quien se convirtió en héroe
revolucionario o tenemos el pastor que
va a ser presidente y también tenemos
este niño que defendió la bandera hasta
la muerte yo de verdad no me imagino
ningún relato en la historia de los
países más épico y más significativo que
un niño defendiendo la bandera de su
país con su vida pero algo importante es
que este estas historias de los países
se construyen a través de relatos pero
también se construyen a través de
símbolos por ejemplo el calendario
azteca que significa el calendario
azteca para todos los mexicanos lo hemos
pensado es un signo de unión méxico es
un país bastante plural somos muy
diferentes pero no importa si vives en
yucatán
no importa si vives en baja california
todos somos todos todos como mexicanos
somos el pueblo azteca
quiero que tiene las monedas todas las
monedas del país el calendario azteca
eso nos une eso crea un sentido de
pertenencia bastante importante y eso
nos hace sentir mexicanos que más nos
hace sentir mexicanos un montón de cosas
la cultura la comida la música pero
principalmente las personas los mismos
mexicanos y sus logros tenemos
científicos que son premios nobel
tenemos artistas que fueron
reconocidísimos en todo el mundo tenemos
también músicos que son exitosos en
todas partes tenemos bailarines en los
mejores conciertos a nivel mundial
tenemos astronautas claro que eso
también nos hace sentir orgullosos como
mexicanos
y para poner esto un poco más serio en
2015 una de las casas encuestadoras más
sensatas este y más profesionales en
méxico pregunto justamente esto sobre la
historia los mexicanos estamos
orgullosos de nuestra historia el 80 por
ciento dijo sentirse muy orgulloso o
bastante orgulloso de la historia igual
recuerdo que el año pasado uno de los
periódicos de más circulación en el país
preguntó están de acuerdo con la frase
la patria es primero imagínense qué
fuerte es esa frase la patria es primero
y el 78% de los mexicanos contestamos
que la patria es primero estamos
orgullosos de nuestra historia ustedes
que creen yo definitivamente creo que
estamos muy orgullosos de nuestra
historia pero
yo me acuerdo perfecto que cuando estaba
en secundaria salieron dos francés que
para mí me hicieron reflexionar
muchísimo acerca de la historia la
primera fue una de jorge santayana un
filósofo español que dice y que
seguramente todos la conocen aquellos
que no recuerdan el pasado están
condenados a repetirlo es muy famosa y
esta frase te hace reflexionar igual que
esta frase de george orwell que salen en
el libro de 1984 la historia la escriben
los vencedores que puse que me puse a
pensar con estos dos franceses que en
nuestra historia y la historia de todos
los países está llena de ironía está
llena de ironía que es la ironía según
la rae ahí está no expresión quiero
entender algo contrario a lo que se dice
generalmente como broma disimulada un
sinónimo de ironía podrían ser sarcasmo
y nuestra historia está lleno de eso y
hay que aceptarlo pero hay que
entenderlo también
y aquí las preguntas que quiero resolver
con esta charla es ayuda a la ironía a
nuestra historia
y para qué sirve la ironía en nuestra
historia después de todo lo que vayamos
a tocar vamos a ver si podemos resolver
estas dos preguntas y para eso quiero
hacer el reto es hacer un recorrido por
120 años de historia de méxico y ver
estos pequeños destellos de ironía en
cada uno de estos momentos épicos que ha
vivido el país por ejemplo vamos a
empezar desde el principio que pasen
1810 el 15 de septiembre de 1810 empieza
la lucha por la independencia y cuando
hablamos de la independencia tenemos que
hablar del padre miguel hidalgo pero no
es el cura miguel hidalgo en la historia
y en los libros lo marcan como el padre
de la patria pero en realidad miguel
hidalgo el padre de la patria hay
historiadores que dicen que miguel
hidalgo ni siquiera mencionó a méxico en
ninguna de sus batallas no lo mencionó
simplemente que buscaba miguel hidalgo
miguel hidalgo en ese momento quería que
los criollos llegaran al poder porque
porque españa estaba siendo ocupada por
francia y estuviera representado que
tuviéramos un poco más de autonomía
quería esa autonomía el padre hidalgo
pero también quería
de igualdad sin embargo cuándo empezó
todo este movimiento revolucionario
cuáles fueron cuál fue el grito del
padre hidalgo muchos de nosotros incluso
los niños en la primaria creen que el
padre y era algo gritó viva méxico y no
es así tres cosas grito que viva la
virgen de guadalupe viva fernando
séptimo el rey y viva y muera el mal
gobierno
yo a méxico no aparece
incluso poco antes de morir entrevistan
a hidalgo y después de esta guerra
sangrienta desordenada que emprendió le
preguntan padre hidalgo por qué pasa
todo esto él contesta muy sinceramente
no sé me deje llevar por este frenesí
eso fue lo que dijo el padre el que
nosotros llamamos padre de la tate y
entonces tenemos que avanzar quien
siguió la lucha independencia este josé
maría morelos y pavón y por qué es
famoso josé maría morelos y pavón porque
hace los sentimientos de la nación este
primer esbozo de acta de independencia
de los mexicanos que después se
convierte en la constitución de
apatzingán y esa constitución de
apatzingán tiene el nombre formal de
decreto constitucional para la libertad
de la américa mexicana que le debemos a
morelos
que empieza a meter la palabra mexicana
dentro de documentos oficiales tal vez
él tiene más sentido alrededor de esta
construcción de lo que es la mexicanidad
lamentablemente morelos muere y no puede
seguir con la lucha independencia pero
sabemos que la lucha independencia la
siguen la consuman más bien
iturbide y vicente guerrero con este
famoso abrazo de acatempan no dejan 11
años de lucha sangrienta ininterrumpida
en nuestro país con un abrazo qué es lo
que pasa
realistas e insurgentes se ponen de
acuerdo y sientan las bases para la
independencia pero nace méxico como país
no nace méxico como país en 1821 nace el
primer imperio mexicano
la pregunta es cuánto duró este imperio
mexicano
tres años esta paz entre realistas y
esta paz entre insurgentes duro nada más
tres años no duró nada más y después en
1824 que sale quien nace ahora sí en
1824 podemos hablar de que nacen los
estados unidos mexicanos eso quiere
decir que a lo mejor ahorita en el 2024
en unos años todavía con el presidente
actual podremos celebrar el verdadero
bicentenario de la independencia y del
nacimiento de los estados unidos
mexicanos cuál es la ironía detrás de
todo esto
nosotros estamos celebrando el 10 desde
el 15 de septiembre y lo celebramos con
una euforia con una felicidad pero
estamos celebrando el inicio de una
batalla que no tenía como fin último
crear un país y le decimos el padre de
la patria a alguien que ni siquiera
había pronunciado la palabra méxico esas
son las ironías de nuestra historia que
pasa después de 1924 ya que empezamos
como país
este empezamos divididos esta paz entre
las listas e insurgentes queda atrás en
1824 y empiezan una serie de grupos que
se pelean unos contra otros en 1824
empezamos con las logias lorquinos
contra escoceses los de orc y nos
querían que los españoles fueran por
completo y los escoceses querían que los
españoles todavía vivieran en mexico y
esta batalla se transforma después en
centralistas contra federalistas y los
centralistas querían el poder desde el
centro del país y los federalistas
querían la autonomía en cada uno de los
territorios qué es lo que pasa con esta
pelea de centralistas y federalistas en
1836 este texas se quiere independizar
porque pues porque no estaba de acuerdo
con los centralistas estas divisiones
entre nosotros estas divisiones entre
centralistas y federalistas york y los
escoceses libertadores liberales
conservadores lo único que dejaron es el
país hecho pedazos estas batallas en la
cabeza de las personas estas batallas de
ideología lo único que hicieron fue
desmembrar nuestro país
1821 cuando somos el primer imperio
mexicano abarca vamos desde el sur de
costa rica hasta casi vancouver en
canadá teníamos casi 5 millones de
kilómetros cuadrados que pasa tres años
después se nos va el 11 por ciento del
territorio se va chapas y todo
centroamérica en 1824 los estados unidos
mexicanos nacen sin chapas que pasa
después en 1836 les decía se va a texas
se independiza texas sólo llevábamos 15
años como independientes y perdimos el
32 por ciento de nuestro territorio 15
años
15 años que pasa después 1848 devastador
algo devastador perdemos la guerra
contra estados unidos y nos quitan la
alta california y nos quitan nuevo
méjico perdemos cuanto la gente dice que
la mitad del territorio no el 59% del
territorio lo perdimos con la guerra de
eeuu y por último llega a santana en el
53 y vende la mesilla y terminamos de
quedar desarmados como país y queda al
final como lo conocemos ahí está 1853
vendemos la mesilla y así quedamos como
país
1848 les platicaba perdemos la mayor
parte del territorio y ese fue un
episodio trágico de la historia pero con
esta ironía pues no podíamos aceptar que
simplemente habíamos perdido una guerra
esté sin precedentes y que habíamos
perdido tanto territorio y que hacemos
que empezamos a desarrollar historias
empezamos a desarrollar esta historia
con esta ironía y entonces nos dicen y a
todos los niños en la escuela les dicen
que el 13 de septiembre de 1847 los unos
niños héroes que eran cadetes
defendieron el castillo de chapultepec
con valor con heroísmo hasta el último
momento y entonces estaba uno de estos
cadetes que se llama juan escutia y que
antes de que fuera víctima de las balas
de los eeuu y que los eeuu iba a agarrar
la bandera este y sería va a llevar el
prefirió enrollarse y aventarse para
protegerla
que más irónico que esta gran historia
lo que si pueden comprobar los
historiadores es que esa bandera en
realidad llegó a eeuu y estuvo en manos
de eeuu e igual la academia de west
point nueva york
qué es lo que no podemos comprobar que
en realidad con escutia se haya aventado
y la haya protegido
eso es la ironía con la que estamos
viviendo y con la que nuestra historia
ha crecido después de perder esta
terrible de guerra seguimos dando nos
perdonen la madre entre liberales y
conservadores y llega a 1857 y en 1857
salen las leyes de reforma y con las
leyes de reforma se da la libertad de
prensa se da este el registro civil se
le quitan los bienes a la iglesia esta
reforma liberal importante que nos costó
una guerra civil de tres años de darnos
unos contra otros liberales contra
conservadores
y al final está adaptada a esta ganancia
de los liberales no duraría mucho tiempo
porque en 1862 que pasa los
conservadores le hablan a los franceses
llegan los franceses y empiezan a
invadir méxico
pero hay una de las historias de las que
más orgullosos nos sentimos que pasa el
5 de mayo de 1862 los mexicanos le
ganamos al ejército más importante de
todo el mundo destrozamos a los
franceses imagínense qué orgullo
ahí está la frase de ignacio zaragoza
diciendo las armas mexicanas se bañaron
de gloria ese 5 de mayo
pero para qué sirve para esconder esta
gloriosa batalla el 5 de mayo nada más
sirve para esconder un poco que un año
después estaríamos aplastados y que
dejaríamos de existir como país y
volveríamos al segundo imperio mexicano
quién es el responsable de esta batalla
del 1862
irónicamente muchas veces decimos que
los franceses pero quien le comenzó
quien la inició los conservadores
mexicanos que le hablaron a los
franceses para que vinieran a quitarlos
y entonces también irónicamente llega un
emperador a méxico un emperador y esto
es lo más chistoso un emperador de corte
liberal que hace cuando llega a
maximiliano todas las leyes de reforma
que había promulgado juárez la respeta
libertad de prensa este líquido le no le
regresa los bienes a la iglesia todas
las leyes de reforma las respeta eso
pues obviamente le causó conflictos con
los mismos conservadores y con los
mismos y con la misma iglesia es más
maximiliano le pide a juárez que era el
máximo representante liberal maximiliano
le pide a juárez que entre en su equipo
como ministro de justicia
evidentemente cuales no acepta pero esto
es la ironía el conservador maximiliano
en realidad era una persona bastante
bastante liberal
y qué pasa a juárez nuestro icono
mexicano liberal que representaba la
influencia mayor de juárez dentro de su
política siempre fue la logia
qué quiere decir que más que apegado a
los principios y a las raíces indígenas
que fueron donde nació en las yemas
acaso a las élites de la logia masónica
esas son los contrasentidos y esta es la
ironía que encontramos dentro de nuestra
historia
después de que termina el segundo
imperio este llegan los liberales
nuevamente al poder y poco tiempo
después llega a el poder alguien que
conocemos bastante bien todo los
mexicanos el porfiriato en 1877
imagínense después de todo este desmadre
que tuvimos todos estos más de 50 años
donde nunca nos supimos organizar le
decimos y le reclamamos a porfirio que
es un autoritario que fomentó la
desigualdad por primera vez con porfirio
logramos crecer económicamente como país
desarrollamos la industria eléctrica la
industria petrolera la industria textil
trajo un gabinete de científicos
encabezados por limantour y revolucionó
por completo el sector financiero en
nuestro país
infraestructura como nunca caminos
puentes ferrocarriles hicimos todos los
que existen son de la época del
porfiriato arquitecto
arquitectónicamente también que hicimos
bellas artes paseo de la reforma el
ángel de la independencia que hicimos
como nunca y decimos que estuvimos bajo
el yugo autoritario y desigual de
porfirio pero quien tuvo que venir para
quitar a porfirio la revolución que pasa
en la revolución
llega a madero el apóstol de la
democracia tres años dura madero en el
poder cuando de repente esto se
convierte en vez de una revolución que
cambió el sistema político económico y
social lo único que pasó fue una
revolución de caudillos una guerra de
caudillos de unos contra otros sin
sentido y sólo por el poder
madero duró tres años en el poder y
después llega a huerta y lo mata llega
al huerto al poder y después llega a
carranza exilia huerta y mata a zapata
carranza como presidente y quien tiene
que llegar su ex amigo obregón que mata
a carranza y que también mata francisco
villa y después obregón que estaba en el
poder y que iba a tomar su segundo
período presidencial quien llega a
flotar con las calles y lo mata nos
vimos nada más en la madre
sin sentido para quitar a un autoritario
mi pregunta es cuál fue el resultado de
la revolución en realidad acabamos con
el autoritarismo después de la
revolución
lo único que hizo la revolución fue
institucionalizar el autoritarismo y
entonces después de 35 años con porfirio
como el único autoritario lo que hacemos
después de la revolución es un partido
político que ahora es el potente al
poder y dura 70 años de 35 años a 70
años y aquí empezó la vida democrática
de nuestro país y en 1929 con la primera
elección del pdr que pasa quien compite
una de las personas más reconocidas en
méxico en ese momento en el mundo quien
era josé vasconcelos jose vasconcelos
fue el primer secretario educación el
noveno rector de la universidad autónoma
desde la universidad nacional autónoma
de méxico era un gran pensador y era una
de las personas más reconocidas que
empieza con esta campaña él empieza a
crecer en números y le empieza a ir muy
bien en la campaña y a medida que va
creciendo en la campaña le van matando a
todos los liderazgos represión
quien era el candidato oficialista
pascual ortiz rubio en 1929 como acaba
esta primera lección 93% pascual ortiz
rubio y 7% el resto de los candidatos
a partir de ahí el futuro electoral de
mexico se definiría
qué es lo que pasa después de este
análisis
nos hemos dado mexicanos contra
mexicanos nuestro país es el resultado
de muchos conflictos internos que no
supimos resolver de forma positiva
y aquí es donde volvemos a preguntar
ayuda a la ironía en nuestra historia y
para qué sirve yo diría que si ayuda a
la ironía dentro de nuestra historia
yo diría que la ironía es el principal
elemento que forma este orgullo mexicano
que forma este sentido de pertenencia
por el país es muy importante dentro de
nuestra historia porque si contamos la
historia de alguna forma como la estamos
platicando nuestros momentos seríamos un
país completamente depresivo ningún país
podría tener una historia hay un
nacionalismo contando las derrotas y
contando los malos momentos
pero qué pasa esta parte irónica de la
historia no tenemos el monopolio como
mexicanos de eso que creen en perú
también está alfonso ugarte un héroe
este patriótico de perú que él no el se
enrolla la bandera pero iba arriba del
caballo y saliente un acantilado también
para proteger a la bandera y también
tenemos una niña aero en bolivia y ella
cuando llegan los chilenos a invadir
bolivia agarra una bandera que se está
quemando la sacude la seca y la guarda y
éste la defiende y también está juancito
pinto un niño que era tamborilero y que
dentro de esta pelea entre chilenos y
bolivianos agarra después de que estaba
aniquilado bolivia agarra las armas y va
y enfrenta de forma valerosa al ejército
chileno
estas historias están en todos lados y
esto es lo que nos hace sentir
orgullosos y está bien tenemos que
reconocer que es la ironía y que es la
verdad y tenemos que aprender a partir
de ahí aprender cómo está estructurada
la historia de méxico y cómo nos hace
sentir
la historia de méxico
y para esto quiero terminar con dos
reflexiones bastante sencillas una de
jorge santayana que dice el país un país
es el producto accidentes geográficos e
históricos por tanto la nacionalidad es
un accidente irracional la lealtad hacia
un país debe ser condicional debe ser
condicional su patriotismo tiene que
subordinarse a la racionalidad a cosas
como la humanidad y la justicia por
supuesto está bien que amemos a méxico
pero tenemos que ser racionales y justos
qué pasa si mañana de 60 por ciento los
mexicanos deciden que queremos hacer un
muro al sur de la frontera estaríamos de
acuerdo yo no estaría de acuerdo a mí no
me parece internacional y me parece
justo
este amor al país debe estar
condicionado a que la racionalidad y
justicia
se vale ser irónicos en la historia
claro que se vale y es lo podemos
abrazar pero también hay que conocer esa
ironía
y por último una de las francés estoy
parafraseando a uno de mis autores
favoritos que se llama christopher
hitchens que al final de su libro es de
cartas a un joven disidente menciona si
fuéramos un poco más autocríticos
escépticos e irónicos podríamos
verdaderamente aprender del pasado
en vez de alabarlo de forma indulgente y
desinformada
estamos irónicos seamos autocríticos
está bien que amemos a méjico y
cambiamos ironía pero tenemos que saber
que esta ironía se construye y que es
sobre la que estamos parados se vale que
amemos a méxico pero lo hay que amarlo
por las cosas correctas hay que amarlo
por su historia hay que amarlo por su
orgullo y su sentido de pertenencia pero
también hay que amarlo desde la
racionalidad y desde la justicia gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]